this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to yet another episode of biographics
I'm your interim host Carl small and
today we're talking about Charles I 12th
the last great king of Sweden and as
with all the videos here at biographics
this one is based on original article
submitted To Us by a member of our
writing team that person being in this
case Ben Adelman follow them on social
media below if you are so inclined while
you're down there you can click that
like button and you can leave a comment
with suggestions or feedback and then
subscribe if you want to see more videos
like this you know thinking Carl
shouldn't be asking that at the end of
the video like yes I should but YouTube
analytics show us that the earlier in
the video I asked people do those three
things the more likely people are to do
all three of those things isn't that fun
let's get to
it so at the dawn of the 18th century
Europe found itself torn apart once
again by War so while the great powers
of the West were fighting over who
should inherit the Spanish Crown in the
north another life and death struggle
for territory and honor was taking place
Sweden is a peaceful country today but
300 years ago she was a force to be
reckoned with boasting one of the most
feared armies in Europe the Kings loued
as Warlords without peer Charles the
12th seemed to be yet another one of
these Kings his General ship proving
extraordinary despite his very young age
and yet for all of his victories on the
battlefield Charles the 12 will prove to
be the Swedish Empire's on doing is he
led his country to disaster with
stubbornness and refusal to compromise
it would eventually set all of Sweden's
neighbors against him and he would live
to see most of Sweden's vast territorial
gains conquered by his enemies before
dying in a futile effort to restore the
situation but before that let's start as
I like to say at the
beginning Charles also known as Carl
with a C or the proper spelling Carl
with a K was born on June 17th 168 2 in
Stockholm his father King Charles X 11th
who'd have guessed it had ruled Sweden
since he was a small boy thanks to the
premature death of his own father Sweden
had propelled itself to the ranks of the
great European Empires in the 1600s
acquiring vast stretches of territory
around the Baltic Sea largely as a
result of Victories on the battlefield
they had even established a colony in
the new world called creatively enough
New Sweden on the banks of the Delaware
River in the modern-day United States
the secret to Sweden's success was the
strength of her Army in a time when most
armies in Europe consisted of poorly
trained conps Sweden had trained a
professional military machine that had
routinely defeated every single opponent
sent up against it and it's noted that
some of the finest generals from this
period wore the Swedish Crown including
Gustavus Adolphus the famed Lion of the
north unfortunately since most of
Sweden's successes had come at the
expense of their neighbors Denmark
Poland Lithuania and Russia he left
almost totally surrounded by enemies
that just chafed at the chance for
Revenge Charles 11th had fought numerous
wars in the decade case before the
younger Charles's birth while also
tackling domestic issues caused by the
cost associated with Sweden's rapid rise
to power you know armies don't pay for
themselves Charles was the only son to
survive infancy meaning that a lot of
pressure was put on him from a very
young age since he was to eventually
inherit the Crown Prince Charles was
known as being highly intelligent by his
tutors particularly in the fields of
Science and Mathematics he also learned
quite a bit about war as you imagine
from his illustrious father regularly
accompanying the King on Military
Maneuvers and Troop inspections from a
very age Charles the 11th is skewed most
of the pump and Circumstance associated
with kingship preferring to dress in
rough clothes and eating simple food his
son followed his example and took it
even further still throughout his life
Prince Charles rarely drank alcohol of
any kind preferred to sleep rough in the
woods like out with his men instead of
like in his big palacial Palace and he
certainly spent more time praying than
he did feasting he also routinely almost
systematically avoided members of the
opposite sex during his lifetime he
never married father had no children and
had no mistresses that historians are
even aware of this has caused some
speculation in the century since that
Charles may have been homosexual it's
also possible that he was asexual or
just simply driven by his deep religious
Faith to wait until he found the right
woman and since the only guy who really
knows for sure is dead I guess we'll
never know for sure
either wait a minute guys do you hear
that it's The Telltale pitter patter of
business antier here to talk about
today's sponsor
Squarespace I love that I just I don't
know and you know what all my sponsor
spots is going to have this stuffed an
eater in it and I'm never going to
explain it you know what I think
business anteater needs a website a
business anater does need a website yeah
and it needs a website with lots of
cookies on it cuz I bet an eers is a
really good at eating cookies
specifically the crumbs can you imagine
like you know if you spilled cookie
crumbs on the floor you your come go
little ho well today's sponsor is
Squarespace an all-in-one website
platform you can use to create a
beautiful website just for anteaters
well you could you can make a website
about anything that you wanted to do and
anyone out there who's ever tried to
make a website and gone screw this knows
that a service like Squarespace is
incredibly useful if you don't want to
be sat there going screw this so I'm
just wondering what would a antia
website need well I you wouldn't
understand the fluid engine Brad but we
humans with our humaniz brains can what
is the fluid engine so with the fluid
engine it allows you to customize
everything in your website and has like
a dragon drop system and you know what
dragon drop kicks so much ass I love
dragon drop like you know what I don't
like I don't like entering data I like
clicking and goingo cuz like you can
just easily move stuff around if you're
not happy with it you could just
rearrange stuff as someone who grew up
in the '90s and had to use word try I
remember try to drop drop a like nich is
getting flash by War flashback so you
drag a photo into a Word document and
goes well I guess this is ruined so I
think another thing that would be useful
for an antia based website of course yes
tell me m would be the various blogging
tools that are available because the
anti could tell its story it could yeah
and like an anti would be typing so slow
because an have those big claws people
don't know an is that they walk on their
Knuckles and have these big 3in long
claws so they'd be typing like my dad
types when he's on his computer like
this that's a fun noise oh no it nearly
stopped the recording when I did that so
yeah the blogging tools you can share
stories photos videos and updates and uh
Squarespace also allows you to
categorize and share posts another thing
I think the antita could utilize is you
could create course on how to be NTA
because if you have a very specific
skill or live life experience that other
people want to know about why not charge
them to hear about it like and I can
just imagine Snoop being there like are
you tired of you gluing a vacuum cleaner
to your face and crawling around on all
fours just imagining
that walking around so thank you to
today's sponsor Squarespace check out
Squarespace at squarespace.com
biographics for 10% off on your first
purchase of a website slain using the
code biographics and a fun thing we've
been ending on in our sponsor spots is a
bonus fact for you our audience so guys
would you like to hear about how honey
badgers are endangering themselves yay
so I think it's pretty well known online
at this point that the honey badger is
one of the most Fearless animals to
exist like they famously will just
attack lions with abandon and in
captivity will frequently escape from
captivity to attack lions we've made an
entire video about that in the past but
did you know that um like no one really
knows how long a honey badger can live
for because they attack other animals
that are much larger than themselves
with such impunity and throw themselves
headlong into danger that they've never
seen one die of old age in fact while
the honey badger is not considered to be
endangered it is frequently at risk of
putting itself onto the endangered
species list due to how frequently they
get themselves killed by walking
headlong into things that would kill
them like lions and um uh bear traps and
the like isn't that
fun Charles the 12th was propelled to a
throne at the tender age of 15 after his
father died in 1697 of abdominal cancer
he spent the next few years at home
consolidating his power as would be
reformers found themselves dismayed at
the Young King's emergence as just as
much of an absolute monarch as his
ancestors were if not more so we say
this because while he was unfailingly
polite to his advisers and always
listened to their CS he would ultimately
make his own decisions and stick to them
no matter how unpopular they proved to
be however Fallen Intrigue soon brought
the young king into conflict with his
neighbors an alliance was formed between
tar Peter of Russia King Frederick of
Denmark and Augustus elector of Saxony
and king of Poland Lithuania that would
direct their combined military might
directly against swedens they figured
that with a young king on the throne
Charles was 18 When The War Began in
1700 and by attacking from all
directions at once they could overwhelm
their historic enemy and reverse their
territorial losses of the previous
generation so a pretty sound tactic All
Things Considered Charles Reed his
country for war directing his Army and
Navy to first attack Denmark which was
attacking his ally the Duke of Holstein
when he left Stockholm to join his
troops no one realized it at the time
but this would be the final time the
king would ever see the capital of the
country he ruled the Swedish Fleet
outmaneuvered their Danish counterparts
to land Charles's Army near Denmark's
Capital which what is it folks you
remember from school Copenhagen in
conert with Allied English and Dutch
forces they bombarded the city for 6
days until Frederick capitulated was
forced out of the alliance against
Sweden Charles now turned his forces
towards the Eastern end of his empire
particularly the large Russian army
commanded by Peter that was laying Siege
to the city of NAA in the Swedish
control provinces of ingria today the
border between Estonia and Russia
Charles's lieutenants were apprehensive
to say the least at the thought of
facing the Russians Not only was the
Swedish army exhausted from the force
March through hard country and foul
winter weather just to reach NAA but the
army that faced them was four times
larger than their own however in a
critical twist of fate the SAR had left
his army on the day before Charles's
Army arrived on the scene no one is
really 100% sure why possible answers
range from Peter simply not being aware
that the Swedish were on their way there
which makes sense it was 300 years ago
you could only really tell what was out
there as far as he could see or just
simple cowardice which I personally
don't believe when an army A quarter of
size of your own is rolling up on you
but this is what historians think
whatever the case on November 30th 1700
as the swedes approached the Russian
trenches outside of Nava Peter was not
in command of his troops so who was well
the man Peter attacked for command
wasn't even Russian he was a German
Baron named Charles de Croy who had been
sent from Saxony as a diplomatic Envoy
but was asked by Peter to take command
because the lack experience on the part
of his Russian commanders and The Story
Goes that de Croy refused multiple times
to take on this command and has be plied
with alcohol to be basically coerced
into doing it so Not only was he like
relatively inexperienced did not speak
the language of the majority of the men
he was leading but he was also nursing a
terrible hangover from Russian vodka the
swedes of course had no way of knowing
any of this at the time and when Charles
ordered Army to attack the Russians his
advisers feared the worst just as the
battle lines have being formed a
ferocious snowstorm whipped up and
Charles advisor told him to call off the
attack until it had all blown over but
Charles rather astutely pointed out that
the storm was blowing right into the
faces of the Russians while it was at
the backs of the swedes he wanted to use
this to his Advantage the battle of AA
was a tremendous success for the swedes
and for Charles the 12 the poly train
Russians had trouble even seeing the
approaching swedes until they were
almost on top of them and poor
communication meant that de Croy could
not bring his overwhelming numerical
superiority to bear on his enemies as
the swedes just storm the trenches and
prove their skill in hand-to-hand combat
the result was a massacre to say the
least the Russians died by the thousands
many of them drowned in the Frozen Nava
River when the bridge they were fleeing
across broke under their weight by the
end of the battle the swedes had killed
wounded or captured some 18,000 Russians
while suffering only 2,000 casualties
themselves overnight the Swedish King
was the Tor of Europe but NAA turned out
to have a dangerous downside too it made
Charles extremely overconfident in the
capabilities of both himself and his
army while also causing him to
underestimate his opponents especially
the Russian
s with Denmark out of the war and
Russia's Army annihilated Charles turned
his attention to the last remaining
enemy he had Augustus of Saxony the
Polish King alarmed by the sudden
collapse of his allies attempted to sue
for peace but Charles would hear nothing
of it before setting off on his campaign
Charles told the Swedish Parliament
rather famously that he had resolved to
never fight an unjust War but to never
end a legitimate one except by defeating
his enemies so the young king would put
that into practice now he swore that he
would not make peace with Poland until
Augustus had been removed from his
throne to the end he invaded the Polish
Lithuanian Commonwealth in 170 one
aligning himself with the confederation
of Polish nobility that was dissatisfied
with augustus' rule after capturing
Warsaw Charles marched to Kow where
Augustus was gathering his army the two
met in the Battle of klou on July 19th
1702 when Charles decisively defeated a
Polish Saxon Army twice the size of his
own Force Augustus was able to escape
with most of his army but much of this
prestige in Poland had been destroyed
and Sweden began to attract more polish
magnates to his side by 1704 he'd
actually managed to convince enough to
join his side that they managed to vote
to depose Augustus and elect Charles's
preferred candidate this is a name that
I hope I pronounce correctly because it
is very polish stannish law leki in his
place but stannish law had no
independent power base which meant that
Charles needed to spend even more time
and resources fighting Augustus and his
allies to keep his man on the throne it
was not until 1706 when Charles marched
his army into Saxony itself it was able
to force Augustus at sword Point into
agreeing to the piece of aldat which
confirmed Sally's love to the Polish
Monarch and ended s his participation in
the war this had taken some 5 years but
Charles had finally gotten what he
wanted whether it would have any benefit
to Sweden however his advisers were
engraved out about at this point Charles
was in a potentially very powerful
position he had a Victorious Army a
sparkling Sterling military reputation
and he just so happened to be positioned
at the borders of Western Europe which
was locked into a Denis conflict of its
own the war of the Spanish succession
the conflict which ped France and Spain
against England Holland and Austria had
been raging since 7 02 with no clear
winner in sight the injection of Swedish
arms on either side could very well tip
the balance in either's favor but
Charles declined to take on any role in
the conflict to the West supposedly
convinced not to intervene through the
personal mations of the English
Commanding General the Duke of malb this
was not the first time that Charles
refused to play the role of arbiter of
Europe and like before it was because he
had personal business to sessle with his
enemy and in this case that was
Russia
while Charles had been let's put it
diplomatically busy in Poland SAR Peter
had been trying as fast as possible to
modernize the army that had been beaten
so badly by Charles at NAA and then
using it to patiently fulfill his goal
of opening up the Baltic Sea to Russia
in 1703 he found a new Port City on a
site of a captured Swedish Fortress
naming it St Petersburg and the next
year finally captured Nava after a long
and costly Siege Peter had captured much
of Sweden's Eastern territory but not
all of it including the main Swedish
Fortress of Ria in modern day laia
Charles's advisers have been begging him
for years to end his seemingly
unprofitable campaign in Poland and
concentrate on Russia who they viewed as
the Real Enemy but Charles would not be
persuaded he was convinced that Peter
and his army were no real threat easily
dealt with when he was good and ready
just as he had done many years before
ignoring the fact that it was only by a
Confluence of like remarkable good luck
that he was able to win the first time
on New Year's Day 1708 Charles was
finally ready he led his army not to
recapture the Baltic territories he lost
but an audacious invasion of Russia
itself he ultimately aimed to March
directly on Moscow the Russian Capital
take it and force Peter from The Throne
just as he done to Augustus and it was
certainly a a bold move too bold in the
opinion of his advisers but Charles
would not be persuaded he was an
absolute monarch in every sense of the
word and he had to listen to No one's
counsel either in Stockholm or on the
battlefield initially Charles met with
with some success in the field just as
he had everywhere he'd gone since 1700
he was able to take advantage of the
weaknesses in the Russian command
structure once again the sa was not with
his Army and the two leading commanders
sherov and mikov who were said to have
clashed on strategy in the Monarch's
absence the result was another decisive
victory for Charles at hwin in July 1708
which allowed Charles to continue onward
with Invasion unimpeded directly towards
Moscow unable to defeat the swedes
outright Peter and his generals instead
turned to a scorched Earth strategery
clearing the countryside for miles
around the Swedish Army's advance of any
food or resources they low the swedes
deep into Russian territory not offering
battle but instead wearing Charles down
through sheer attrition and then the
winter setting and anybody out there who
spent any Real Time online consuming
content around like military history
knows there's one real rule when it
comes to Warfare in Europe and that is
don't invade Russia in the winter time a
rule Charles the 12 was seemingly not
aware of so Russian Winters have a
pretty nasty reputation but this
particular winter was one of the coldest
Europe had seen in 500 years and the
Swedish army suffered terribly by the
spring of 1709 half of Charles's
soldiers were gone Frozen or simply
starved to death but still the Swedish
king would not Retreat instead he laid
Siege to a town of pava in Ukraine
hoping to seize the supplies St there
instead it was where Peter found
him
the Russian army Charles face at PA Hara
in 1709 was not the same one he beaten
in NAA in 1700 the S had done much to
reform his troops as part of his mission
to westernize Russia from the ground up
it was also massive numbering some
75,000 men the S Swedish army wasn't the
same either worn down by hunger and
almost a decade of near constant
campaigns far from home they numbered
less than 20,000 making things worse was
the fact that Charles wasn't able to
lead his army personally he'd been
wounded in the foot some days earlier
and couldn't walk ride he was resigned
to being born on litter at the rear
forced to leave active command to his
subordinates it was probably around this
point that the Swedish King realized
he'd been led into a pretty nasty Trap
by Peter he reasoned the only way to
keep himself from being starved in
submission was to attack the Russian
army before their fortifications were
complete so on July 8th 1709 the Battle
of pava began as they had many times
before the Swedish troops Advanced
gloriously against their enemies with
all the Valor that A Century of
Victories could give an army and they
fought quite valant too as they had
before but this time there were simply
too many Russians Russians that were
disciplined enough to stand up under the
musket fire go toe-to-toe with the
Swedish lifeguards in hand-to-hand
combat this time it was the swedes that
broke and ran Charles having no real
choice but to go with them as he watched
his army disintegrate before his eyes 3
days later at oh this is a word Perna
the destruction of the Swedish army was
made complete the remaining troops were
compelled to surrender to the Russians
unable to go any further only Charles
and five 00 Cavalry Escape crossing the
border into territory control by the
Ottoman Empire the Ottomans were no
friends of the Russians and they
welcomed the Swedish King who set up
court in Exile in the Fortress of Bender
in mova he ended up spending the next 5
years there refusing several peace
proposals that would seen him return to
Sweden it was like Charles was just
unwilling to concede defeat instead
occupying himself with diplomatic
intrigues his most successful effort I I
guess was convincing the Ottomans to go
to war with Russia in 1710 providing the
king with a huge Turkish Army to do
battle with Peter but thear had
intrigues of his own and successfully
Bri the grand vazia into making peace
with him sending Charles back to mova
the rest of his schemes ranging from
clandestinely supporting the jackaby
rebellion in Britain to bribing Indian
Ocean Pirates to colonize Madagascar on
Sweden's behalf were somewhat less
successful in the meantime Sweden
suffered defeat after humiliating defeat
as Russia conquered the rest of Sweden's
Baltic possessions including in 1710 and
then invaded and occupied Finland as
well for good measure meanwhile Sweden's
defeated enemies Rose back up again as
enemies are want to do Augustus
regaining the Polish crown and Denmark
resuming their attacks against Swedish
possessions and as if all this wasn't
bad enough more enemies decided to help
stick the boot into Sweden with
opportunistic Prussia and Hanover
entering the warh hope and to grab some
territory for themselves so at this
point virtually all the territory
outside of the Swedish Homeland was lost
her entire Empire collapsed and carved
up and still Charles W would not give up
he only returned to Sweden in 1715 when
he realized there was a real risk of
losing his crown if he did not come home
you know to the country he ruled not to
mention he kind of worn out his welcome
with the Ottomans and one attempt by his
host to remove the king and his retinue
from Bender in February 1713 actually
ended in a full scale battle between the
earthw Allies the Skirmish at Bender or
the calik resulted in the deaths of over
200 ottoman Janis series as well as 20
swedes so yeah it kind of won on that
welcome paper
thin when Charles finally returned to
Sweden after 15 years away he found his
kingdom in pretty Dire Straits his
demands for more troops and War
materials over the years had decimated
the Swedish economy there were no more
young men to work the fields
manufacturing and trade had all but
dried up because you know the country
was now surrounded on allsides by
hostile neighbors and the population of
his domains had shrunk by more than 10%
since he'd left and yet despite all of
that Charles still would not make Peaks
not without the restoration of all the
territory that he lost which nobody was
willing to agree to because they'd
already kicked Sweden's ass so instead
he set about rebuilding his army again
so that he could once again go out on a
campaign again this time his Target was
Norway for some reason because why not
make an enemy of those two controlled by
the Danish he felt that if he could rest
Norway from his enemies he'd have open
access to the North Sea which would
restore his trade links particularly
with the dut he would also hopefully not
the Danish back out of the war Charles
invaded Norway in 17116 and briefly
managed to occupy the capital
Christiania today ow but he suffered a
humiliating defeat and a number of
setbacks including the destruction of
his Supply Fleet by the famed Norwegian
naval hero Peter Torin scold who I hope
I'm pronouncing that guy's name
correctly because I've actually made a
video about him over on my channel fa
feed and over in that video we don't
call him Peter talken stall we refer to
him by his much cooler easier to
pronounce nickname of Peter Thunders
Shield so given to him because he was
declared to be the Thunder that struck
down the enemies of his nation's people
and the shield that Protected Their
Waters not one to be put off Charles
tried again in 1718 this time at the
head of an army of some 40,000 men this
time instead of marching just straight
to the capital and trying to depose the
ruler he would first seize the border of
fortresses that had barred his path last
time starting with one near the town of
I again hope correctly Frederick sh
which is today Halden the 1400 men
inside the Fortress did manage to fight
back quite ferociously but steadily the
Swedish trenchers gain ground and that
night Charles rode to the front lines to
inspect the ongoing Siege works and as
he often did Rose himself Head and
Shoulders above the trench line to look
at the walls with his spy glass the King
was used to exposing himself to Danger
while on campaign he was usually in the
thick of fighting in most of the battles
and have sustained several wounds some
serious but this time however his luck
ran out an unknown Danish soldier who
most likely had no idea who he was
aiming at because the king like his
father liked to wear simple clothes shot
the king in the head with a musket round
Charles the 12 slumped to the ground
having been killed almost instantly at
the age of
[Music]
36 the king's body was brought back to
Stockholm and given a lavish State you
all that was most likely held behind
closed doors because many in Sweden were
kind of glad to see him gone that whole
de a 10% of the population thing tends
to do that so because of his
stubbornness he would never have
accepted an end to the war no matter how
many losses he suffered like a gambler
who keeps going at the casino despite
the fact he's lost all his money and
he's now borrowing money from his
friends Charles was convinced that he
could somehow some way turn it all
around with just one more campaign the
Great Northern war finally came to an
end in 1721 with a treaty of NAD in it
Sweden had to accept what was already a
pretty obvious reality at that point her
day of Empire of being a leading
European power were over the void was
filled by Russia and Prussia which
became powerful states in their own
right eventually carving up Poland
between them Sweden would never again
rise to be a major military power after
playing a little more than a bit part in
the poic wars the country adopted a
policy of harsh neutrality that's only
very recently been broken by the
decision of the country to join nato in
2023 the monarchy meanwhile would never
hold as much power as it had during
Charles the 12th day as for the man who
would come to be known as carus re is
rather a conflicted Legacy long held up
as a heroic figure in Sweden he is today
and just as much remembered for his
autocratic style of leadership as he is
for his victories on the battlefield and
the fact that members of Sweden's
Neo-Nazi Community hold him up as a
nationalistic hero hasn't really done
wonders for his reputation but the most
intriguing question surrounding Charles
the 12 since his death is usually what
may have been what if he hadn't been so
bullheaded in his invasion of Russia
what if he hadn't been so young at the
time and made more sensible mature
decisions how long was Sweden's EMP
Empire have lasted if he hadn't lost at
pava no one will ever really know but
one thing is for sure though the ghosts
of Sweden's glorious past for better and
For Worse will continue to cast a large
Shadow over her present and her future
so I hope everybody at home found this
video to be entertaining informative and
educational I certainly found the script
to be all three of those things and if
you are inclined to agree you can go
follow the author Ben Adelman on the
social media links below while you're
down there as mentioned in the intro you
can like comment subscribe all that good
stuff we'd like some feedback
suggestions for other figures to cover
you know maybe there's some people from
history we're not aware of let us know
and we can know get around to telling
our authors to go write some scripts
about them and yeah follow me on social
media if you want to you can find my own
channel fact with C Smallwood I'd like
to recommend the video we did about
Peter wesle toron sto and to end on
here's a little bonus fact about Mr
Peter thundershield and he was well
known for his skill with a sword and
famously once managed to duel three
Swedish drons to a standstill while he
was on the beach and when they were
about to land a cig gra the killing blow
um he slapped all three of their swords
aside um dived into the water and swam
to his boat while screaming not today
and for this reason he is a folk hero
because you don't have balls that big
without somebody making a movie about it
and there is a movie about it but it's
in like Norwegian a language I don't
speak so when I was like scraping
through it to trying and find the
pronunciation I'm like did they say
Peter scon gold did did they that
sounded like it Norwegians a very
difficult language to pass so I
apologize for no out there if I
pronounce his name incorrectly every
time I've said it he's a cool dude
[Music]
cheers